Is fasting obligatory upon all Muslims
or is there a distinct group that Allah
refers to when it comes to fasting in
the month of Ramadan particularly?
>> Alhamdulillah.
There are five conditions to be
fulfilled to make fasting obligatory on
any person. Number one is he or she
should be a Muslim. Number two, the
person should be sane.
Number three, he or she should have
reached the age of puberty. That means
he or she should be an adult. Number
four, the person should be healthy.
Number five, the person should not be in
a state of traveling. He or she should
be settled. There are additional four
conditions for a female to be fulfilled.
If it's a woman, if it's a lady, if it's
a female, there are additional four
conditions should be fulfilled to make
it obligatory on her. Number one is that
she should not be menstruating.
She should not be in a position where
she has postnatal bleeding. She should
not be breastfeeding and she should not
be pregnant. So for a woman if all these
nine conditions are fulfilled then it
becomes obligatory on her and for the
male only the first five conditions have
to be fulfilled to make it compulsory
for them to fast in the month of
Ramadan.